If we only work with two dimensions and want to find one
area under the curve, we already have a good tool for it
and I will remind you now
So let's say this is the x-axis and this is the y-axis
and here's any feature
my function f (x)
And let's say we want to find an area between "x" equals "a"
so this is "x" equals "a" and "x" equals "b"
We've seen this many videos back.
You can take it by taking really tiny widths of "x"
or really tiny changes in "x"
We can call them delta "x" but because they are so small
we will call them "dx"
Very, infinitely small "x" changes
And then we multiply them by f (x)
at that point.
So we multiply them by the height at that point
which is f (x)
So we have f (x) times each of these infinitely small bases,
which tells us the surface of this infinite
narrow rectangle
And since each of them is infinitely small
we will have infinitely these rectangles
to fill the entire area
You will have infinitely many of them,
that?
So the tool we used was a definite integral
A definite integral is the sum of all
infinitely small areas or these
infinitely small rectangles
And the symbol we use is that they go from "a" to "b"
And we've already done many videos like these
solve the integrals
I just want to remind you
What this tells us
This tells us: let's take a tiny change in "x"
multiply it by the height at this point
and you will have infinitely many of these because these "x"
they are infinitely small
so you will have infinitely many of them.
So make an infinite sum of all, from "x" equals "a"
after "x" equals "b"
And that is our standard definite integral
And in this video, we'll expand it a bit
so that we can solve more complex and
wider range of examples
Let's move to three dimensions now
I first paint the xy surface
Maybe I'll leave this to be clearer.
I'm going to bend it a little now,
so that we have a better view.
Let's say this is the "y" axis,
that goes backwards.
You can imagine that by pushing this
and I'll put it down.
So this is the "y" axis and this "x" axis.
Let's say we have some path on the "xy" desktop
And to define it,
I will have to find out the parameters of both variables, "x" and "y".
.......... I'll just change the color,
because I use orange too much.
Let's say that "x" equals some funky with some parameter "t"
and let's say "y" equals some other function with the same "t" parameter
and say,
that "t" will be greater than or equal to "a"
and also less than or equal to "b".
And this defines the path on the "xy" surface.
If you find this confusing, you can look again
to videos about parametric equations.
So when "t" equals "a"
..............
thus, "x" equals "g (a)"
and "y" is equal to "h (a)".
So we'll have this point, maybe here,
I do not know, I draw a random point here.
When "t" equals "a", we draw a point on the coordinates
"g (a)"
as the "x" coordinate.
------------
And the coordinates "y" will be "h (a)".
Just substitute "t" equals "a" to each of these equations
and get values ​​for "x" and "y".
So this coordinate is "h (a)"
And you will gradually increase "t"
until you reach "b"
and get a set of points that looks like this.
This is the curve on the "xy" surface.
And now you're probably saying "what's in common."
with here? "
"What are we doing?"
So I'll write "c" here
which is our curve.
Now, let's say I have another function that connects everyone
point on desktop "xy" with some value.
Let's say I have the function "f (x, y)"
that connects each point on the "xy" desktop
with some value.
So now I'm drawing "f (x, y)"
Here I will make a vertical axis.
Maybe in a different color.
We will call it the axis "f (x, y)"
or the "z" axis if you want.
Just some vertical axis here.
So if I know "x" and "y" and put them in
my function "f (x, y)", I get some point.
So I can paint the area
which represents "f (x, y)".
All this will be much clearer
when I do some concrete examples.
Let's say "f (x, y)" looks like this.
I'll try to paint it as best I can.
And in a different color.
.............
Some surface ...
I paint her part-
Let's say that area
it looks like this.
This is "f (x, y)"
And all this is is that you give me "x" and give me "y"
substitute it into "f (x, y)", and some value comes out
which we draw on the vertical axis.
...............
Example "f (x, y)"?
This may be, for example, not in this case,
"x" plus "y".
.................
These are just examples.
It may be "x" times "y".
when "x" is 1 and "y" is 2, "f (x, y)" is equal to 1 times 2.
But let's say for each point on the desktop "xy"
we draw the corresponding point according to "f (x, y)" and this area is created.